hey ah welcome to the Rotten Tomatoes
studio and we're here to break down
marvel's black panther trailer that just
dropped this morning I'm Jacqueline and
I'm Shagun and black panthers directed
by Ryan Coogler who's teaming up with
chadwick boseman and reteaming with
Michael B Jordan who I know a little bit
what's up Mike blue play basketball talk
to you soon whoo you know from Fruitvale
station and Creed
without further ado can we can we play
this trailer yeah cuz this is fire it's
gonna be so lived
it's almost hella good all right here we
go so we're going into a Conda
so this is Black Panthers like flying
machine I don't know the name of it yet
but it looks bad hasn't been released
yet yeah so fan nerds do not get honest
we do not know the name of it yet when
it does come out we'll have it for ya
this one I wanted to pause real real
quick on this this is definitely mbaku
who is sort of like Wakanda is this
whole nation full of tribes and he is
the guy that's in charge of the mountain
tribe and they're very much at odds with
T'Challa section so he's definitely
gonna be an adversary as we get later on
into the trailer I'm really interested
the guy that plays him Winston is like
six seven and huge we saw him at the
Marvel press line dude is ridiculous so
that's every K Ross played by Martin
Freeman doing a pretty good American
accent talking about basically the
Avengers but how black mantas
good right so now what's your hand
that's Vincent staples Long Beach owns
rapper very very talented I'm a Vince
staples fans shout out to all my people
in the LBC keep playing keep my eyes
want to shout out Long Beach so you know
they need to know who that music was and
trailer and the song is bagged back
which I'm also very big fan and the one
thing I was gonna say velvet so staples
is he's all about afrofuturism which is
totally the look of black panther which
is this whole like african nation but
futuristic with the technology and just
the look in the feel so I feel like this
trailer is just setting up the whole
world I can't wait there we go again
okay so you see they broke through right
there
remember what Conda is a nation if you
remember from the teaser trailer that's
also that's got high tech but it's
hidden right it's hitting on the
continent of Africa do you want to give
them a little backstory I'm like how
Marvel actually created Wakanda and I
glide what kind of so especially yeah
we'll do a little bit of a basically the
condemnation is sort of kept in hiding
because of vibranium which if you
depending on which comic series you
follow there was either a meteorite or
something that allowed them to have
vibranium it's what Captain America's
shield it's with all the black Panza
technologies made out from his suits to
his talons that's why in civil war
there's that great shot of him
scratching down cabinets shield because
it's made from that same material anyway
the reason why they steep themselves in
sort of like secrecy is because they
have this valuable mineral and they know
that if they don't keep themselves
secret they're gonna be attacked and
ulysses cloth we'll get to in a minute
play by Andy Serkis yes in a live-action
role he's one of the few people that's
made it into a condo so he's gonna play
a big part into this Danai gurira she
plays Michonne in The Walking Dead and
she plays here I want to get a good look
at this costume one of the door milosh a
she's directing it looks like and flying
this plane like would note wood might
bite touch just with their hands I'm
just like she gets her nails done at the
same studio I get mine done just in case
anybody knows like we sit next to each
other from time to time to get a
mani-pedi anyway but not no no I
actually do we do that
Wow Wow I believe you don't hate all
right so here we go to Charlotte in the
uniform it looks like they're just
coming back to makanda after the events
of Civil War one thing we definitely
know for sure is the actual events of
Black Panther literally like 10 minutes
after Civil War happens
- Charlie goes home and he has to face
the repercussions of what he did by sort
of announcing himself to the world
through the events of Civil War so door
Milosh a listen look at Angela Bassett
just looking exceptional I mean I love
her I love her and that she plays two
challahs mother ramón de Academy
award-nominated the Angela Bassett ya
Academy award-winning Lupita and young
Joe yeah one thing I will say about
Lupita Nyong'o is character is Nakia is
one that doesn't necessarily have the
allegiances that she's supposed to have
all the way through I'll just put it to
you this way
in the comics sometime her allegiance is
unclear don't always assume that she's a
good guy or a bad guy and she may be
have allegiances that we find out in
this I don't know if that's what they're
gonna go with in the movie but but it
gives us something it gives us something
from the comic books it gives us
something to anticipate what I would say
that's really important is just a quick
shout out to the type of career arc that
chadwick boseman is on he's played
Jackie Robinson in 42 he's played James
Brown and get on up and now he's playing
basically the most important black
superhero in the Marvel Universe I
apologize to anyone who's a serious
blade fan and while Wesley didn't blade
and Wesley you carried that thing but
this right here from his appearance and
the Avengers to having his own
stand-alone movie that's a really big
deal so we know Chadwick watches
everything so you're doing your thing
man yeah and Thurgood you know Thurgood
Marshall Marshalls and theaters now
check it out all right here we go so
back to Wakanda
ah that is gonna be the new invite for
you to get into any like black function
from now on that is the greatest so this
is shown on black friends like if you
greet us that way you're in you get it
you got a free advice of the cookout it
seriously so your hook em horns or like
hang ten or like gnarly dude or whatever
whatever whatever whatever your
vernacular is that's us but seriously
everybody's gonna be doing this and I'm
excited for it so this is Sheree which
is two challahs young sister and what
she plays in the comics is kind of a
cute character to his like if you want
to call him the black James Bond which a
lot of people have said she is the chief
science technology officer at his gear
and tech fresh exactly and they say that
her mind is rivaled only by Tony Starks
so she's definitely going to be a
character that is gonna be instrumental
to keeping him together and keeping them
going so can you pause it right there
because I know a lot of us have through
concussion and that tell the truth tell
the truth from Will Smith Thank You Chad
referred as an as an African person
myself Nigerian thank you for doing a
really good African accent because it
doesn't take me out of the movie all of
the characters hit their mark perfectly
with the accent if you're going to do an
African character well if you're
watching copy with Chad the voice coach
here we go
so basically back black Josephine's
amazing a badass he's more the great
tech looks like he's protective upon it
all right Jordan and this is big for me
because I'm a fan of Michael B Jordan
and I know him we play basketball
together and he lost me for a moment
when he was in the Fantastic Four like
that Fantastic Four movie but Marvel
Redemption yes they do give you a
Redemption that and he's pulling you
know what he's pulling his Ryan Reynolds
never run - Green Lantern and wait this
time comeback is Deadpool let's talk
about Captain America - I mean like you
start with the crappy role as the as
Johnny from Fantastic Four and then you
move on to Marvel you get a great role
those Captain America and now kill
monger kill monger you don't know main
antagonist
looks like here he's busting out Andy
Serkis is Kari yeah ulysses klaw out of
whatever kind of imprisonment he's in
here oh love that showing him being a
hero legend I love that they're showing
the legend of Black Panther in this like
the mythology because remember this is a
religion and this is a religious like
place holder the Black Panther and even
though he's King
that's the royalty aspect the symbol
first people so kill monger just based
off the comics I don't know if they're
gonna go with this basically he has a
like sorted history with Wakanda like
maybe he got kicked out and he's trying
to come back that's why he's trying to
be this revolution I don't know but this
is the thing this from the comics so
read the priest run if you haven't
Christopher greased in a run a black
panther this is not a spoiler I would
say read that they said that Ryan
Coogler based a lot of what he did in
this off of it but based it off of it
does not mean it's gonna be the same
thing doesn't mean it's gonna be exactly
get it
what happens now
free so them so for anyone who's
actually interested in some of what
Michael B Jordan has on his body that's
a that's a type of scarification that is
kind of prevalent in some African
countries there is actually a tribe
known as like the leopard people and if
you've ever seen the movie marked for
death
if you've ever seen screwface the
character he had some of those same type
of scarification and it is actually
tribal artwork so just so everyone knows
like that there is a real reason why he
why they did that for what he's wearing
and then to twist on what they did
basing off the comic skill monger used
to have armor that had little spikes in
it and so now it looks like they're
taking that and twisting it to the
scarification I just love how ryan
coogler takes the mythology from the
comic switches it on its head for
something that's real and authentic for
like a modern audience I absolutely love
it and this home and you see him
transform into what that's an oh crap
moment because that's the first time you
see somebody outside the royal family
their outfit so let me just put a little
theorizing out there for you okay this
is my theory total Theory ulysses klaw
is the guy that stole vibranium we saw
that an age of Ultron chill monger
breaks them out of jail then we see a
shot of kill monger with a vibranium
black panther suit so maybe that's why
he broke them out right I'm down for
that so down for it so now you got to
try and keep track for the rest of the
trailer which black dancer who's doing
what yeah so that's T'Challa
I just want to put this right now if you
hear the voice that's rapping over the
remix of bag back
that is dil Gil scott-heron yes the
revolution will not be televised if
anybody was wondering whether this was
gonna be like an unapologetically black
movie like this right here the trailer
just set it off because what did you
expect from right from from Kugler
Michael B Jordan from yes this is what
you want yeah and we're happy to get it
so thank you and it goes back to this
idea that Black Panther was not
necessarily inspired by the Black
Panthers of the 60s but this song
particularly the revolution will not be
televised was definitely used as so I
love that they put in the trailer
okay talk about the stunts or just the
fact that no I really wanted to give a
shot of Ulysses cause arm if you looked
at it really closely it broke apart
it's like transforms into a gun yeah
unfortunately we have to wait till 2018
for this movie to come out but it's
going to make that whole New Year's it's
gonna make it well Black History Month
this is gonna be the best Black History
Month in the history of everything
February 6 really yeah those Black
Panthers coming out it's gonna be the
best Michael Skakel sign that one it's
going to be a good no no this is this is
my Star Wars I've told everyone since
like the first announcement came it was
Ryan Coogler and Chadwick Boseman
I've been so here for this movie and
this trailer does nothing but make me
love it even more
I love seeing all these characters just
so pretty
they did a good job the trailer is great
the trailer doesn't give away the whole
movie you're not really quite sure what
the plot is going and that's really a
sticking point for me sometimes these
trailers either don't say enough or they
say too much yeah I mean I think there's
a lot of stuffs too open-ended this is a
great thing with these comics like if
you look at Civil War that was based off
of a car
run that was really famous but they
twisted it they made it different and I
have a feeling like again if you have it
please check out the priest run like I
said a black panther and read that it
has a lot of stuff that I think they're
gonna pull from here about isolationism
and after your futurism and kind of how
a child has to war with the fact that
he's this symbol to the world but he's
also a man of his people not to mention
the Townies he coats is writing the
Black Panther comic book which is a big
deal like we're talking about a comic
book now that's being basically elevated
to a high art yeah so if you are a fan
of what you saw in the trailer go out
there read the comic book buy the comic
book as well speaking of by my hello
shirt you can find that on the Fandango
fan shop page also where I had my
lightsaber from the last time you saw
Jaclyn and myself yeah definitely yeah
and we'll keep breaking down trailers as
long as Marvel keeps putting them out
and we appreciate this early morning
surprise they gave us but uh yeah that's
it first yeah from the rotten tomato
studios
[Music]
you